das ist mir jetzt auch zugeschaltet wir
haben gerade ein video gesehen das waren
sie die in diesem video verhaftet worden
sind es sind wirklich unglaubliche
aufnahmen kann sich das gar nicht
vorstellen hellichten tag einfach von
einem von der belebten straße wie haben
sie das ganze erlebt und vor allem wie
lange waren sie dann inhaftiert ich
hatte glück ich habe einen
installierendes kind deswegen hatte mich
schon nach sechs stunden freigelassen
das war natürlich spare ich habe
geschrien ich habe mich beim getrampelt
weil wir wissen sie ich wurde von einem
mann in zivilkleidung festgenommen und
sie stellen sich auch nicht vor und die
sieg alles furchtbar aus und wir werden
mit ihm in den bussen transportiert ohne
kennzeichen das sieht alles so aus als
ob das die banditen auf die straßen
ähnliche leute festnehmen genauso sieht
es auf jeden fall aus wie ist denn die
situation gerade in weißrussland wir
haben es gesehen noch immer gehen
hunderte tausend menschen auf die straße
und das schon seit wochen
sehen sie eine veränderung im land jetzt
haben jetzt die mir angst als wir nach
dieser verhaften seit der letzten woche
hat sich die situation verändert und
jetzt nehmen sie auch die frauen fest
und dabei sehr grausam meiner tor
hingegen wurde am samstag ein
haarbüschel aus den haaren genau hier wo
jetzt gezeigt wird in dieser menge war
ich mit meiner freundin zusammen dort
hatte er ein haarbüschel ausgerissen und
das war wirklich furchtbar durch ein
wunder haben wir uns damals gerettet am
samstag und jetzt aber packt haben alle
frauen angst denn die polizei hat
anschauen eine anscheinend ein befehl
jetzt auch gegen die frauen gewaltsam
vorzugehen und unser protest wird jetzt
vielleicht ein heimlicher denn jeden tag
auf die straße zudem brauchen wir uns
nicht mehr
es ist wir haben furchtbare angst
trotzdem werden wir natürlich am samstag
und am sonntag da jede woche gehen denn
an diesen tagen gibt es massive proteste
alle fachleute gehen auf die straßen
sie sagen es selber die gewalt jetzt
auch gegen frauen wird immer stärker
natürlich wächst die angst dann auch bei
diesen aufnahmen kann man das natürlich
absolut nachvollziehen aber die frage
ist trotzdem wie wollen sie dann jetzt
weitermachen muss man fast sagen
lukaschenko gewinnt dann über die
demonstranten oder werden sie einfach
neue wege finden um weiter gegen den
diktator vorzugehen
daran sind prozess verwandelt sich jeden
tag
natürlich werden wir nie aufhören die
empörung in der gesellschaft ist so groß
dass wir einfach nicht stoppen können
das was jetzt gemacht wird die ganzen
lügen die man uns auch tisch da die
ganze gewalt das ist in dem maße in
düren dass die leute nicht mehr weiter
ruhig weiter leben können
aber der protest ist jetzt vielleicht
räumlicher wir tauschen er im telegramm
werden jobs gebildete wir tauschen
informationen aus
wir gehen abends auch die straßen aber
in der nähe von unseren häusern wo wir
zusammen mit unseren leuten mit unseren
freunden nachbarn etwas zusammentun
singen tanzen trinken oder süßigkeiten
essen und wir zeigen dadurch wieder
schon ganz wenig unser protest nicht
mehr im zentrum der stadt und dann in
der nähe von unseren häusern in den
parkanlagen
wir schmücken unsere gegend mit unseren
fahrern mit den historischen fahnen die
jetzt zum symbol des protestes geworden
sind auf jeden fall auch vielen balkons
und auch den fenstern sieht man
heutzutage diese fahnen und streifen
außerdem beginnen die leute allmählich
ihren protest auch den arbeitsplätzen zu
zeigen
auch diejenigen die protokollstrecke
waren sind jetzt verstehen jetzt etwas
beginn etwas zu verstehen und sie gehen
nicht mehr auf
lukaschenko auf die straße obwohl sie
dafür gefeiert werden können also eine
neue art der proteste aber die proteste
gegen den diktator werden weitergehen
vielen dank an sie dass sie uns diese
einblicke gegeben haben als eine der
starken frauen von weißrussland
dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren